so part of the unofficial free agency
involves the reports yesterday that the
bears will sign
once they are able to do so andy dalton
to a one-year
10 million dollar deal to become their
quarterback and
hey when anytime you're talking eight
figures you assume he's installed as the
starter you assume he's the guy just
like
ryan fitzpatrick in washington ten
million dollar deal for him
he's the guy doesn't take you out of
play to draft a guy
right but to me that that tells me
no trubisky maybe falls hangs around i
think he's got a low salary
no trade for russell wilson andy
dalton's our guy this is our guy
pending whatever we may do in round one
yeah i mean it seems that way
it does i mean it's underwhelming if
you're a bears fan certainly
but i do think the bears exhausted all
options in trying to get russell wilson
from everything i know
uh people i trust around the nfl they
also were making calls to the houston
texans and deshawn watson of course we
know
that that's not happening right now but
uh
they had to make a move at some point so
they went with a guy and andy dalton
who like a tyrod taylor but even more
you know of course has a little more
starting experience as a low-level
starter
or one of the best backups in football
you know and except on this occasion
you know with andy dalton too there's
there's
commonplace as far as knowing the system
and how that works right bill
is there as one of the offensive
coordinators offensive minds
so he's going to understand you know the
the ins and outs of the system that way
and they're stuck they're stuck in a
spot right now where
there's really not any other options out
there at quarterback
other than the draft or maybe if
something happens with a desean watson
or maybe if something happens with the
jets and they finally just let it be
known that hey they're taking the
quarterback at number two
and then maybe that can free some guys
up where sam darnold becomes free
you know there's still the jimmy g
aspect out there but how long can you
wait
it's a little like you know the new
england patriots with cam newton we
talked about that yesterday
you know at some point you want to start
formulating your team and just getting
it together instead of sitting there
going
whoa okay it's early april and we still
didn't get our quarterback and we got to
figure this out so
uh i don't blame them for this even
though i don't think it's going to
excite the bears fan base a whole lot
but they got to do somebody they're
going to have nothing they're going to
have nothing and then and then they're
going to get then they're going to get
voles
squeezed they're going to get squeezed
to to over
pay for sam darnold to give up a first
round probably
right in 2022 right after round one of
2021
and same thing applies to the bears that
applies to washington
now that they have a veteran to whom
they're going to pay a base
rate of 10 million it's not as obvious
as
the picks go through the teens that that
you
are in the quarterback market you don't
have to be in the quarterback market and
maybe you don't get jumped and maybe
there's a quarterback there that you
would be interested in
because a team behind you is thinking
yeah they're not going to go quarterback
they have their guy
and and those two teams washington
chicago are back to back bang bang 19
and 20.
so they had to do something they had to
do something they had to move
and and look andy dalton took the i know
he goes to the playoffs
no doubt it's not like he's horrible no
and he had moments last year for
the dallas cowboys went to minnesota and
beat them i mean if you're the bears
you know you're going to minnesota at
some point this year and they're coming
to you right there's a guy who took a
cowboys team and beat the vikings
no i i hear you there's there's there's
some positives there
there there's no doubt about that you
know it's a it's similar to nick foles
except he's better than nick foles
you know he's got a little more
athleticism to his game you know
quicker release a little bit more of an
aggressive nature that way
so and like we talked about he knows the
system added to that you know you talk
about like the drafting thing
i just can't imagine the bears being in
the draft you know for
for quarterback play at least i i don't
envision that
neggy and pace are you know we know the
the seats hot their butt's hot so i
don't think they're going to waste a
pick on a quarterback at this point they
got to do everything they can to make
this year work
i mean i almost look at them and go okay
it's playoffs or they might be out or
you know if they barely miss the
playoffs okay maybe they save themselves
that way but
uh it's i just don't envision the
drafting of the quarterback you're right
maybe there's a trade that happens
something like that but it takes the
pressure off the situation
and at least they got one guy here they
know they can rely on
there is one argument to be made yeah
how persuasive it will be
that if you do draft a guy in round one
let's say some guy slides down the board
that they've convinced others in the
organization they really like
right that they end up getting that that
dispensation they end up getting
another year beyond 2021 so we can see
what
the guy they drafted does in 2022. that
would be the football political reason
to consider taking a quarterback at that
spot because that's the thing if you do
take a guy that naggy and pace like
and you fire both of them after this
year you've used a first-round pick on a
guy that the next regime you may say
i want him right so uh that's that's a
reason
to at least ponder it but you're right
their interests are best served by being
as good as they can be
in 2021 and now it looks like andy
dalton's going to be the guy
that they try to do that with hi i'm
mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports